the forest is slowly growing back even
starting to outgrow the huts it now
shares these hills with this tree used
to be the only reminder of the thick
canopy cut down to make way for the
hundreds of thousands of reinga who fled
here but what you see here was a forest
reserve three years ago it's taken a
multinational effort by different aid
agencies together with the Bangladeshi
government to host almost 900 thousand
people on this challenging terrain but
what happens now this is the third year
of the Rohingya crisis the first year
was all about saving lives and the
second year was about stabilizing the
situation in the camp that you see and I
would say that the third year really has
to be about preserving people's hope and
their dignity for the year for the
future and when we look at the hills of
Myanmar just over there that's where
people want to go that's what they tell
us they want to repatriate but multiple
attempts to start a voluntary
repatriation program have failed no one
here trusts the Myanmar government will
ensure their safety it hasn't allowed
any observers to visit the rahega areas
and Bangladesh has made it clear it
can't host them forever for the refugees
there is a lot of time to think syed
ahmed is the father of three young
children living here now for almost two
and a half years somehow we are managing
and for that
we are very grateful to all those who
are helping us but we are deeply
concerned about our children's future
and their education although we are
getting by but if we end up staying here
longer then it is very likely our
freedom and movement will be more
restricted there are already
restrictions here the rahega can't leave
the camps nor access the main roads
after dark and recently the military has
started to build a fence around the
camp's perimeter the local Bangladeshi
population is also becoming frustrated
with the refugees this situation is not
sustainable in the long term but there
seems to be little international
pressure on Myanmar to change it it's
almost two and a half years on and still
no one has been held to account but what
happened to the rahaga
these camps are the size of some of the
world's capital cities but where
everyone has a story of tragedy
and trauma it seems the world is simply
accepted that this is just the way it is
this vast landscape refugees hidden away
in far southeastern Bangladesh is simply
a new reality it's a reality no one here
wants to accept with their lives on hold
everyone wants to go home me and Mara's
mountains can be seen from all across
these camps but as things stand for now
it may as well be a world away Stephanie
Decker al-jazeera in the Ranga refugee
camps of southeastern Bangladesh